could pickleball replace the mall
instead of buying khakis you can play a
sport that's
wacky
I know
true apparently balls around the country
are turning to pick a ball to fill
vacant spaces left by stores that closed
during the pandemic it's the athletic
activity so irrelevant even trans women
ignore it
according to people I know pickleball is
a sport it's like tennis if you don't
like to move around a lot
it's also a medical condition if you get
stuck in a jar of gherkins
pickleball was invented in 1965 the year
cat was born
you win by hitting a ball over a net
until one opponent eventually gets bored
and leaves
yet somehow the amount of people playing
has jumped 159 percent over the past
three years and that includes a number
of those players who have fallen and
they can't get up
it's the current sport of choice for
late middle-aged suburbanites who hit
the courts before the relief factors
weren't off and the Cialis kicks in
we call that the Mike Baker Sweet Shop
[Laughter]
and now courts are taking over spaces
formerly occupied by retail giants like
Bed Bath and Beyond Old Navy and sacks
although not everyone is getting the
hang of it
step in there and hit the ball out of
there
[Music]
and here I thought he was just bad at
broadcasting
oh that was so mean what is the message
here cat like the one of the the
greatest things that we grew up with
malls shopping malls is now being turned
into like activities for retirees what
does this say something's happening you
know that I don't like activities I know
you do like I don't know what this is
nobody would ever invite me and that is
the right call uh Bed Bath and Beyond's
like a really sad place though is it
yeah it's sad you just wonder like who's
buying those snacks maybe yes I've
always wondered that that's part of the
Beyond that's part of the Beyond yeah
it's like see that was the problem with
Bed Bath and Beyond is that the Beyond
was so so amorphous it could be anything
like I once bought a sawed-off shotgun
at Bed Bath and Beyond yeah I just did
you really I don't know who this is for
I mean I I don't know why you would do
it I I don't know I although I've been
to Dave and Busters in Times Square a
few times as of late oh I like that the
combination of uh activities and
shopping except they got rid of the
shopping well that's yeah you know what
this was this is saving malls and it's
not just pickleball it's like Trampoline
World and there's all these different
activities so now when people go to the
mall they go to do activities because
you just go to Amazon or you order
online so you know they still the only
thing they still have is Hot Topic
apparently Hot Topics still hanging
strong but uh
so they're having activities so it's
like all these new things for people to
go the problem is that that used to be
the malls used to be on lock at six a.m
to 9 A.M for old people to do their laps
yes you'll remember that you see the old
folks walking their laps yeah now they
have tracks and they can play all kinds
of games it's not just that because uh
kids now have something to do you take
them to the mall especially in places
like Chicago and where you have cold
Winters in the Midwest and stuff
hopefully they're putting bulletproof
windows up on the Moss but they're
having more things for them to do
instead of going to the store so this is
actually the last ditch effort to save
your precious childhood memory of what
is a mall yeah because once the
activities go they're gone yeah it's
funny oh the Hot Topics the only one
that sticks around you know instead of
dressing rooms they have self-harm rooms
you know Mike
you and I grew up around the same time
uh late 50s yeah early 60s we don't talk
about we were raised by the same uh
lovely old lady yes that's right well
she took us in at the orphanage yeah uh
racquetball courts do you remember them
everybody was playing racquetball in the
mid 70s was it got 15 minutes for for uh
for five bucks for 15 minutes get the
little racket but you know what
racquetball would wear you out though
that was a real sport compared to
pickleball now pickleball uh I will say
a couple of things first of all the
tires is absolutely right this is
probably the only thing that's going to
save the malls and Commercial Real
Estate is sitting on a cliff oh my God
you're right so if if there was a mall
that had uh what would you call it like
world
to be clear okay trampoline Okay
trampoline well if you had that if you
had the pickleball facility if you had
maybe like a Spencer's Gifts if you had
a brothel in there okay we're gonna
place it again a place to get wings then
I'd go
I'm sure you never banged your secretary
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of eerie though Morgan to think
that like it's almost like malls were
like cemeteries now of cemeteries of
dead shops it's like you drunk drive by
then you go I used to do that there I
used to do that there and now it's just
like people playing with their little
rackets I don't I don't listen I'm a
Suburban mom so as long as they don't
come for Target because if they come for
Target we're going to have a problem you
don't want a Target on target I think
it's okay I mean I have a little kid
whenever it's raining or it's cold I
take her to the mall to run around
there's a ton of shops and you know
people get to eat also is this a child
yeah my kid oh okay just wanted to
clarify you said you had a little kid
yeah and we're very careful about it
child abductions here so I did very fat
and pregnant with her in 2020. there's
pictures you know what you're doing
Morgan do what I do with my kids when
it's rainy and cold outside yeah send
them outside
can't it's my little princess toughens
them up did you know but you know as
Americans we like struggle with our
weight so I think anything that's
getting us to move is a good thing so I
you know I think I'm kind of for it but
I do love Hot Topic by the way I went
through this grungy I know it's hard to
believe now but I went through this
grungy phase as a teenager and I thought
Hot Topic was like the coolest thing
ever
yeah
we're cool yeah
yeah yeah I keep telling you something
topic once really I was pretty proud of
it until I went to go look at it but it
was surrounded by boob shirts yeah
no one's ever buying this shirt yeah can
you move it to the other side I'm just
mad when they stopped selling the ice
cubes you know with women on them on the
glass or you put the glasses in their
bikini falls off that's the only time I
ever
had that pin too that you turned upside
down yeah I did yeah you only had you
could hold it with one hand yeah we
really did shot at the same time
I don't know what you're laughing at
anymore most people don't they're coming
up me I keep walking into your bear
traps
our guests shoot the breeze about Gators
and pipes and bears and trees
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else